hey up guys my name is CH welcome back
to my code review series the series in
which I take a look at all the various
code and projects you send me right I
don't know why I do that right so first
of
all we're in the new office might still
be a little bit echoey in here so it'll
take a while to to settle in I uh I
won't I won't give you a tour just yet
because I'm still like basically
building parts of it I pretty much
optimized this camera angle just to show
the good parts so the stuff that's off
camera anyway for the longest time now
we have been looking at the 2,000 hour
game engine someone made a game engine
spent 2,000 hours on it and well I had
some thoughts on it so the previous
video I'll have it linked up there but
really like the previous five code
reviews have been all about that but
today since we are here in the new
office I thought it would be only
fitting to look at a new project and so
I found this email path Tracer project
review request and the screenshots look
pretty good so I haven't taken a look at
this yet but I'll explain why I chose it
first of all you guys have been begging
for the r tracing series to return and I
know I'm sorry I've just been going
through a lot in life at the moment and
I don't have time to sit down and give
that series the attention it deserves so
I promise that next year things are
going to happen the other reason is that
I don't think we've done a path Tracer
in this code review series yet I know
we've done Ray tracing or Ray traces
that people have submitted but from
memory that was a while ago from memory
that was like the rate racing in a
weekend kind of thing like it was fairly
small scale whereas this looks like P
racing and it's done in open so I expect
this is on the GPU and architect it a
bit differently so hopefully we can dig
into that I mean I haven't taken a look
at this yet but this might be a
multi-episode thing as well so let's
have a read of this email hi Cho my name
is Edward I'm 15-year-old programmer
from Ukraine I've made a path Tracer in
C+ plus using opengl that I've been
working on for about 5 months right so
that's 3,650
hours here is a link to the repository
we'll obviously take a look at that in a
minute the project contains a visual
studio solution file to keep everything
nice and simple so everything should
just work work this is what the 2,000
hour game engine was like so I'm getting
a little bit of PTSD but aside from that
I have made a video on why that's
probably not how you want to set things
up I'll have it linked up there the
proper way to set up C++ projects
obviously it's subjective it's my
opinion but that is the video to watch
and I would recommend if you are just
making Visual Studio solution files
project files committing them to gith
HUB repositories you might want to take
a look at that to see if that might suit
you better features so we got three
different types of objects Cube sphere
and plane Okay so I expect this does not
just support arbitrary meshes made from
triangles which is not you know terrible
I mean 15 years old 5 months so let's
just keep that in mind three different
materials so we got light sources
emissive materials okay so we can have
materials themselves be light sources by
being emissive we got rough and metallic
and
lens lens I'm expecting maybe they mean
like glass or something like something
like this would be lens maybe depth of
field effect I like how the um how the
letters are are are Bal just so that we
we know that's do guys you can load any
image you want for the sky box png or
HDR okay cool I I'm expecting that has
to be like an equ angular or a cube map
or something uh I guess we'll see we got
some controls wsd space and left shift
move the camera Mouse rotate the camera
how to show you why make a screenshot
cool feedback I'm looking for
optimizations code structure okay cool I
like talking about that stuff thank you
for reading my email hopefully you will
get a chance to review my code best
wishes Ed PS I don't have much
experience in C++ I learn it mostly off
of YouTube and your videos and that I
think is supposed to be like a smiley
face because people from that region
tend to just add like right closing
parentheses to mean like kind of like
smiley faces instead of writing like the
colon and the whole thing so I don't
think that's a mismatched parentheses
all right so here is the GitHub
repository we got some libraries with a
Y beautiful love to see that so yeah I
mean this looks pretty good I'm I'm kind
of excited to take a look at this
actually cuz it does look really good it
seems to be open gel there's a bunch of
useful stuff here I'll obviously have
the link to this repository in the
description below if you guys want to
take a look at it as well now I just
want to stress if this does look cool to
you and you want to learn the math that
goes behind something like this because
believe me it's basically purely built
off of math you can take a look at my R
tracing series if you like if you have
some extra time this holiday season then
it's a really good opportunity to get
stuck into this stuff with the sponsor
of this video brilliant.org now
brilliant.org is an amazing website
filled with lots and lots of really high
quality courses on various stem topics
the math that goes into Ray tracing it's
there you can learn like all of it there
even if you're an absolute beginner you
can start with their Everyday Math
course but then as you get better you
can move on to algebra linear algebra
calculus and that will really teach you
pretty much everything you need to know
but why learn it on brilliant the reason
why I love brilliant for this kind of
thing is because all of their courses
are extremely engaging and interactive
they're super visual like take a look at
this calculus course for for example
look at how you can move these sliders
to manipulate the numbers and Visually
see what's going on that kind of
connection with the math I think is
really really important if you want to
learn it well and quickly but then it's
not just playing around with these
sliders brilliant will also quiz you to
make sure that you're actually learning
and retaining this information and as I
mentioned you can get started completely
for free brilliant have a 30-day free
trial that you can use to investigate
all of the stuff that's on their
platform and see if you like it and if
you do go on to like it they've also
been nice enough to offer the first 200
subscribers 20% off an annual membership
so go ahead and be productive this
holiday season 30 days is plenty of time
just go to brilliant.org Theo check it
out for yourselves huge thank you
brilliant.org as always for sponsoring
this video we got some scenes here
anyway I'm just going to clone this
we're going to take a look at it locally
that makes more sense okay so I've
checked it out locally this is what we
have a solution file as promised
executable open g.exe it's a little bit
scary got a bunch of shaders here I
wouldn't personally commit executables
if you you do want to make your project
just a little bit easier to access for
people so they don't have to build it
themselves I would make a GitHub release
instead I don't actually know if there
were any GitHub releases here no so you
can make a release instead of doing this
and you can actually upload built
binaries now opening up the solution
file this is what where gred with uh
let's just go ahead and try and build it
in release uh okay we're getting a bunch
of Errors so the should work should and
bold uh is not uh it's uh it's failing
us here so cannot open in there's just
the visual studio project file so let's
take a look at the includes we got
release um okay so include directories
this is an absolute path right okay so
whenever your setting include
directories uh and Library directories
and let's have a quick look at the link
so that's just linking these libraries
and then we have the library directories
setting up the directories for them
whenever you are setting up any kind of
path inside your project files whether
that be in like a build system like
premake or just directly in Visual
Studio project files like this do not
ever use absolute paths because
obviously absolute paths are only going
to be relevant to your environment to
your computer and in this case obviously
to your username there are lots and lots
of ways to avoid this and just do this
differently and by the way my video on
how to properly set up C++ projects
which is linked up there does go through
how to set this up using prake and you
won't have this problem but specifically
for this environment since we are
dealing directly with Visual Studio
project files the way that I would set
this up to fix this is probably just by
using the macros that Visual Studio
provides so instead of us going into
here to get to this libraries with a Y
directory by the way just quickly cuz I
know you're Ukrainian you're 15 you
might not know English that well
libraries is spelled with an i but we'll
leave it like this so to get to this
directory you have basically two macros
you could use solution directory or
project directory and so that will give
us this basically if you're not sure
what the macros are there's this macros
tab over here or this button rather you
can click on it you can type in for
example project directory and you can
see it is this right so that is the
directory of that project file this over
here this vcx Pro File that is this
project that we see up here and this is
the directory is located in there's also
the solution directory for example and
that is the directory of this solution
file so you can use either one I'd
probably use a project directory so I
would generally just write something
like dollar sign and then in Brackets in
parentheses project directory now if you
take a look at macros you also see that
project directory ends in a slash so
here's project directory it ends in a
backs slash so that's why I'm not
putting a backlash here I'm just writing
project directory and then directly
libraries include so let's uh I guess
we'll copy this because we also need to
make sure that we do this for here so
I'm going to go ahead and add that in so
now if we hit okay oh by the way I was
only editing the release unfortunately
so just make sure that you make this
happen
for all of them okay great so let's try
building again no include errors here
and it seems to have worked let's go
ahead and run this see what happens okay
so it's not quite working for me it's
coming up on this Monitor and every time
I try and make it active it just flashes
you can probably see my screen flashing
actually so I think it's like trying to
start either in full screen or something
let's go ahead and fix this so what is
it doing so glad oh weing glad here okay
width and height 19 20 1080 okay that
doesn't seem like full unless it's being
set to full screen yeah I mean it
shouldn't be though cuz it's null oh
that's shared oh right sorry yep so
let's go ahead and not make it full
screen cuz full screen for some reason
wasn't working but also I flipped my
main monitor for the purposes of
recording this so yes okay here we go
this is what we see um viewport doesn't
resize
unfortunately but this is it I can't
stop moving the mouse and also I guess I
have to add an object submit
I have to write something
ASD sphere here it is I wish I think
there are some scenes we can load load a
scene many spheres o all right many
spheres to close oh close close I
thought close was the name of a scene um
why is this not working path racing
settings oh right you have to switch
this is I think the rasterized view if
we go back to the uh repository quickly
cuz I think there was some stuff here so
R it disable or enable the random mode
so we have to press R Hey There It Is
Awesome okay so this does seem quite
whoo why is it getting so bright
suddenly it started off dim and then it
just kind of went bright that doesn't
look right um yeah looks looks really
nice though I'm a little bit sus about
the the brightening SL warmer tones that
seem to be coming out later I don't know
if there's any tone mapping going on and
just if we take a look at if we dissect
this a little bit like this is very hot
versus this you know so I'm that's why
I'm I'm thinking maybe this is HDR but
it's not being appropriately tone mapped
potentially because this is also very
very
bright um I don't know if there's a
light source here there's no light
source it's just the HDR image like the
backdrop itself is acting as the light
source which also could be part of the
problem because depending on what the
HDR values of this image are this could
be like you know 200 or something and if
it's like super bright or 2,000 or
whatever then that can overwhelm the
image so some times like what we do in
Hazel is we actually clip the upper
values of super bright HDR like Sky
boxes basically or environment Maps I
should probably call them because
sometimes they can be so bright that
they just ru in your scene but I don't
know maybe we should open this up in
Rand do and see what the actual values
are because they're hard to see it's
also weird that it just kind of gets
brighter and brighter over time like
this like that I don't think that should
happen it almost seems like the
accumulation is being a little bit more
additive than it should be but anyway
either way this looks really cool I'm
really excited to dive in and take a
look at the AR actually behind it
because it does seem like it's running
fairly quick like it's not the fastest
that I've ever seen but you know it does
seem like okay the camera just stopped
moving why did the camera just stop
moving I don't know the camera just sto
moving but it does seem like it's
running quicker than just kind of CPU
based R Tracer or path Tracer would so I
expect this is in fact done on the GPU
so that's going to be super interesting
to dive in and take a look at all right
so the main M file the main function
over here uh my advice always is this
should be clean this should be as clean
as possible I know people have been
asking for this for a while and I think
it's finally time I think it would be a
good idea for me to make like an
application slame engine architecture
series kind of like what I did with how
to properly set up your projects in C++
kind of like that but for just general
applications and game engines and games
and and all of that because this is a
common thing that I see in almost every
project that is sent to me and it would
be nice to just have a resource to point
towards what I will say though is that
again this person is 15 um and I don't
know what experience they have I don't
know what their background is I don't
know if they're studying this or if this
is just like self-taught so I'm not
being harsh I'm not trying to be harsh
or anything but of course there are
certain things here uh that stand out to
me as being you know something that a
non-experienced person would do and also
I feel like a lot of you people watching
my channel whether it be you're watching
these code reviews purely for
entertainment which is fine but if
you're watching them to learn then a lot
of you are probably in a similar
position where you don't have a lot of
Real World Experience just because I
don't imagine Professional Engineers
watching this content for anything other
than just entertainment while eating
lunch or something like that correct me
if I'm wrong though so as a starting
point I definitely would take the these
things and just segregate them out into
uh into like a window class into an
application class I would have like an
application life cycle and window events
and all of that really well defined
because that's like the heart of your
entire program having things like you
know Shader uniforms being set right
over here inside the main function is
also a little bit weird it's like the
main render Loop is actually in here and
all of the all the draw passes as well
like um you know all of this this is
like a draw call here we' got some some
postprocessing going on we've got the
swap buffers and the poll events and all
the key stuff it's all just done inside
this wire Loop inside the main function
now at a pro of this the good side to
this is that it's easy for me to code
review because I don't have to dig
through files so that's kind of nice but
in general you know this should be
architected differently and the main
reason I think for that aside from the
fact that this is just going to end up
growing and it's going to be harder to
manage is the fact that as software
tends to grow and Branch out to
potentially different platforms and
different render apis and whatever it
might be this architecture becomes
unfeasible it's not not even about code
like how clean is your code and how easy
it is to maintain how easy it is for
people to go in and and and adjust it if
they've never done it before it's not
even about that it's about like what is
physically possible and what is not
which I realize is not that applicable
to this project but that's why you tend
to see you know professional software
architecture differently it's because
the requirements end up obviously being
at a much larger scale and things like
this just simply do not work like at all
whatsoever now let's go up I don't want
to talk too much more about architecture
because uh I've talked about it a lot in
my previous code reviews I'll have a
link to the playlist in the description
below you can just watch all the code
reviews and you'll probably learn quite
a bit of what I would say otherwise I
wonder if someone could make a brand new
code review by patching together bits
and pieces from all the different code
reviews and that's literally what I say
because I tend to repeat myself quite a
lot but I want to talk about some of the
more interesting things today um you
know like openg and how is openg GL used
here how are the draw commands happening
how are the shaders running how's the
rate tracing happening I feel like that
might be a little bit more interesting
than just standard C++ code architecture
stuff so the first thing I want to point
out is that this uh you know what we're
doing here is we're setting up the open
gel core profile to be 3.3 this is quite
old so open Jael 3.3 released 11th of
March
2010 so step one do not use open gel 3.3
it's really really old um I'm glad to
see that the core profile is being used
here because there's also the
compatibility profile that lets you use
licated Legacy things that you shouldn't
um and it won't like be like no that's
an error uh so at least the core profile
is being used however I would not be
using this I'd be using 45 46 something
like that um I mean to be real I
wouldn't be using open gel in the first
place I'd probably be using Vulcan but
again this is a 15-year-old person this
is someone who uh you know Vulcan is
very very heavy it's very difficult to
learn for someone who has like zero
experience so I open gel's fine to use
there's nothing nothing wrong with using
open gel for something like this I will
say the only possible limitation I would
see that like is a real limitation is
the fact that if you would like to take
this and then move it to actually use
like rate tracing cores inside your GPU
and for that you'd have to use Ray
tracing shaders the ray tracing pipeline
that's not available in openg G you need
to use Vulcan or directx12 for that so
um or I guess metal and there's other
other apis as well but my point is you
can't use open gel for that you have to
switch to vcon so so that is a possible
extension of this because if you're
doing any kind of rate tracing these
days I think uh you know the end game
should pretty much always be I want this
to run on my RTX course or on the ra
tracing course on an AMD card whatever
they're called because that opens up
like an entirely new generation of
performance that you definitely want to
take advantage of and as a bonus they on
newer drive like the compatibility is a
little bit like it's not going to be as
good as just standard uh you know I
think this is just using Graphics
shaders to be honest like I don't I
think this is just using the normal
Graphics pipeline I don't think it's
using compute we haven't taken a look at
how the rate racing happens yet but
we'll we'll we'll get to that but my
point was that rate tracing shaders
might not have you know as much
compatibility as compute in terms of
like drivers and support but what tends
to happen is on gpus that do not
physically have RTX cores like a 1080
for example the Nvidia driver will
actually fall back the r tracing shaders
to just run on compute so there is like
a an emulation layer if you want to call
it that that makes that compatible so
that's why I generally advise people to
use you know rracing shaders and the new
array tracing pipelines if they're
making things like that and they don't
need to fall back like you know past the
10 series N Video gpus as an example now
aside from that we obviously create the
window uh now we're using we're using
looks like we're using glad here um I
don't know why we're using glad here uh
so I would not use glad glad um glad is
actually an entire I think glad is more
than wait wait glad no no no no no glad
is good what am I confusing glad with I
was confusing glad with something else
oh glot
glut okay no glad is fine glad is fine
glad is kind of like glue glew as well
gel extension That's the older one glad
I think is what people use these days
man it has been a while since uh since I
did any opengl but yes so glad is this
you can basically pick opengl your you
know core profile 3.3 or whatever again
I'd go with 4.6 um probably core so
that's not too bad that's 2017 um so
pretty much like most drivers past that
date will have support for it it doesn't
mean your GPU has to be newer than this
it means your driver has to be newer
than this that's an important
distinction anyway you pick that it's it
it gives you like a header file that
that loads everything because with openg
if you have any extension that aren't
core Windows for example does not
provide header files for that so what
you tend to do is you basically open up
the dll and get function pointers to
certain extensions certain functions
that are within that that newer open gel
standard so that you can call those
newer functions an example of a newer
function that might be you know not core
and open gel like one uh things like I
don't know if frame buffers were but
things like draw arrays definitely were
not so this you can see is coming in as
a function pointer here it is over here
here's like the signature for it um and
it's going to be loaded as a function
pointer when glad starts up so that's
what glad is used for which is fine uh
we set the viewport straight away I
think um you know we did see a problem
where the the window when the window
resized the viewport didn't uh one of
the reasons for that is I I don't think
I would set the viewport as early as
this because what the viewport is for
open jail is it basically tells you what
portion of the frame buffer you can Rend
it to so if you make the viewport too
small then even if your window is bigger
and your frame buffer is bigger you
won't draw anything outside of that
region whatever region you set here
because it will it will be clipped so in
my opinion this shouldn't really be here
because we might not know the final
finished size of our window like sure
we've requested this size but what if my
screen resolution is less what if I'm on
a laptop that's like you know 1280 by
800 or something then obviously I'm not
going to be able to get this resolution
at least not like physically on my
display if it's off screen then
obviously it doesn't matter but if I'm
not going to be able to get that and
also what if I maximize my window what
if I restore a previously run like
resolution like it's a bit early to just
assume that you're going to get this
exact viewport size here not to mention
that because I am gooy being used you
know I don't think I'm go is being used
for a viewport meaning that there's
there's an actual viewport panel and
that viewport panel will just contain
like the frame buffer image basically
being displayed there in which case you
obviously have to make sure that you're
rendering the size of that IM panel
not your entire application window but I
don't think that's what's going on
anyway I think that it's just rendering
to the full window and the I'm goey uh
windows are being like the I'm panels
being composited on top anyway okay so
we got print open gel info just prints a
bunch of stuff here then we got create
shaders now when you're creating objects
on the stack like that you don't need to
do this assignment thing you can just do
that so I would probably prefer to use
this I don't think there's a difference
in this case if you do that obviously if
you had it on multiple lines then you'd
be creating a default Constructor
version of this object and then
recreating it with um you know a
specific Constructor so like for example
if you did like that but you can see
there is no default Constructor anyway
so that's not going to fly but I guess
it just it just saves a little bit of
space if you write it like that then we
got some other stuff over here we got
the camera we got this wrecked vao so
I'm assuming this is a vertex array
object that makes up like the rectangle
so yeah I forgot open gel you have to
have vertex arrays as well as vertex
buffers very annoying but that's the way
that they choose to kind of lay out all
the buffers uh okay then we got a camera
so we got some stuff
here yeah just using trigonometry that's
fine I mean I probably would use cians
but that's I realized that's probably
next level for a 15-year-old I certainly
was not using cians at 15 so it's fine
you can just use trig that's that's okay
then we got random number generator you
know just using the normal kind of
built-in one to in in C uh not the best
random number generator especially uh
you know to use an array Tracer I have a
video where I talk about how to write a
random number generator in three lines
of code I suspect that this is not
what's being used
for um actually maybe these are being
pre-generated or something update random
seeds okay okay yeah okay uh so we're
doing that and then I'm get like these
yeah they make it to the Shader okay cuz
I was going to say that maybe this is
being used for for like CPU side random
stuff whereas obviously we know the rate
racing takes place in shaders so it
would be different anyway but no this
looks like this array of random values
actually it's not an array because is
these are seeds so what happens actually
let's investigate this so update random
SE this update random seeds and we re
regenerate them there's three of them
for all these and then they they wind up
in the Shader and we update them every
frame yes I'm assuming this is like a
base random number maybe that's being
used um you know in the Shader but it's
just a seed still so we can look at the
Shader where are the shaders actually I
don't think I've found them yet now here
they are so what like what is this
default Shader for example what default
Shader is default okay that makes sense
um so if we look at these random numbers
like where are they being used okay so
yeah so we are actually using them as
part of a hash so the random numbers are
actually kind of being created on the
GPU it's just that we have a seed being
set from the CPU um and then this also
seems like I haven't even to step I
don't think I've even heard of
that but this either way this this seems
like a lot of work to get a random
number um because I have a video as I
mentioned talking about how to do that
in like three lines of code so so I
would probably uh I'd probably take a
look at that again quality of random
numbers especially when you're doing
things like picking new raid directions
and raid tracing related things uh you
know there's a lot of papers talking
about different random numbers that
might be better quality or might
converge faster on what you want
important sampling stuff like that so
I'm not saying that this is wrong uh I'm
just saying that I don't know if if
maybe this person just doesn't know that
there's like a a nicer easier way to do
this or they specifically they've
specifically picked this because it
works really well for their purposes I
don't know I'm just saying that there is
an easier way in my opinion that also
doesn't involve you having to see stuff
uh you know from the from the CPU
because that's also not great having to
set you know uniforms and update
uniforms every frame and also run this
every frame to update random seeds if
you just simply don't need to do that
now um I will say that uh the other
thing that I'm seeing here obviously is
a lot of uniforms uh and no uniform
buffers this should all just be inside a
uniform buffer the biggest Advantage
there really is that all of this like
look at what's going on here this is a
fair bit of code to run every single
frame that will first of all update
every uniform individually I mean I'm
not sure if the if the driver will
buffer it up and then send it in one go
whatever whatever on Earth the
optimizations the driver might do that's
a black box as far as I'm concerned it's
annoying because you also have strings
here that you then have to you know I
mean you're you're doing get uniform
location by string that string has to be
matched with shad of reflection data and
all of that to actually find you know
what variable you're trying to set Again
by name what I would do instead is I
would just create a uniform buffer uh
which contains all of this and then you
just I mean it wouldn't contain uh you
know Samplers cuz you can't put them in
there they're textures but it would
contain all of these just raw values and
then you could basically have a a C++
side struct that allows you to set all
of them normally as you would and then
you just kind of upload that and set
that buffer into the GPU in in one go
just before you draw and that would be
it uh and then you can edit it as many
times as you want on the CPU because
it's all inside just a buffer uh if you
have different sections here or like
different you know for example camera
versus like random stuff versus just
like you know Focus distance and maybe
some you know doth parameters you can
obviously create multiple uniform
buffers if you want but generally all of
this stuff would pretty much probably
I'd probably just shove it into one
uniform buffer then just set that once
per frame and then the benefit there as
well is there's no names there's nothing
like that it's just serialized it's like
just a bite stream of data that you're
just uploading to GPU that's it and it
certainly does not need to be done
individually line by line like this to
set all of these variables because that
that can't be that can't be very
efficient we scroll up a little bit
though cuz we're getting a little bit
ahead of ourselves we were talking about
random so then we got some key again you
know this stuff is so not relevant to
this part it just creates so much noise
that it's nicer to to split it up into
different files different classes stuff
like that okay we're creating a Sky Box
which is uh just a width and height and
then okay so are we then cuz we're not
loading it from file directly oh we are
okay so that's just an HDR image cuz I'm
just wondering like if this is like a
cube map or how does this cuz it looks
like a 2D texture so it could just be
like an I mean the easiest way obviously
is just to take a look at the file on
disk okay so I've just opened one of
these in Photoshop you can see it's an e
rectangular image uh so I don't think
it's you know this is typically not
going to probably go through the same
pipeline as it would if you if you had a
rasterized renderer we'd probably want
to convert that from an equ rectangular
into what is going on getting all these
notification sorry going from a an
rectangular image into a cube map
because that means that it's just faster
to sound sample and obviously you want
to optimize for Speed here Ray tracers
path tracers not you know they're not as
real time I mean they're getting to be
pretty fast and I would still say yes
you want to optimize it but it's
probably not as it's definitely not as
crucial and so that's why um I mean the
the other biggest difference I would say
is that when you are loading an
rectangular image as a Sky Box as your
environment map in Hazel for example the
other big difference is in the
rasterized pipeline uh we will take that
Cube map and we'll filter it across the
mips to blur it like a lot and we'll
we'll do that in a very high quality
slow way and the reason why is because
that blur that blurred Cube map is then
going to be used as the specular inside
the PBR rendering code because it's a
way for us to just make well image based
lighting but also just kind of
Reflections reflections of the
environment map work for rougher
materials that wouldn't have a perfect
mirror likee reflection that is not
necessary here because when we're path
tracing when we're doing all that stuff
we're actually doing that by sending out
a bunch of rays from that one spot that
we hit in order to get those accurate or
rather not accurate blurry specular
Reflections for roughing materials so
we're doing that like for reals you know
but in rasterized we're not doing that
usually for uh actual objects in the
scene we're just doing that for the
environment lighting so because it goes
through that Pipeline and we we we want
to have that blow you generally want to
you generally have to do some processing
to your environment map anyway so it's
not just the equ rectangular into Cube
map conversion it's also the whole kind
of myip filtering chain situation we're
not doing that here so you know doing
this is completely fine obviously makes
it easier you don't have to like
pre-process your uh environment map you
can just load it in as a 2D image and
then just sample it using the eat
tangular conversion to whatever you want
uh you know when when array goes off and
misses and then you want to sample from
the environment map okay we got some
textures here so we got two textures uh
I'm assuming like I mean we're ping it
looks like we're kind of ping ponging
between the two so the render API that
he's got here as well is
that uh textes get created and then used
as the backing for a frame buffer uh and
then we got Bloom and postprocess as
well now this Frame buffer has I guess
two attachments so we got two color
attachments texture and Bloom texture so
it looks like you know the bloom stuff
uh I guess only the so if we take a look
at even I guess the the frag you can see
we've got two outputs we got frag color
and Bloom color so that's corresponding
to this and this respectively so Bloom
color I'm guessing is just going to
contain stuff that's bright yeah and
we're doing that by um just seeing we're
doing the the dot with this versus Bloom
weights that we're using some kind of
threshold and if that's above one then
we've determined that that color is
bright that light is bright and it
should be Bloom so we set Bloom color to
frag color otherwise it just get it just
gets set to zero um not bad uh you know
I wouldn't do this because Bloom is uh
you know Bloom is a subject I have a
video just called Bloom you can go and
watch that um and that you know I'm
assuming this person has not done Bloom
like I did Bloom uh and no it this looks
like just normal giian blur or something
like that and it's you know you can see
split up horizontal and vertical passes
so this is I think just a learn open
jail blur or something like that but
either way um you know proper blur is
done over like 10 or so passes probably
and it's down sampled up sampled Blended
together you know blurred using like
tent filtering and stuff like that like
it's it's a box filtering tent filtering
like there's there's a bunch of stuff
involved and unfortunately well I don't
know if this is necessarily unfortunate
but if you want high quality Bloom you
have to do this um and typically this
kind of filtering this like
pre-filtering as it's called Uh to
separate the bloom stuff that would be
done in compute later uh and you don't
necessarily need to worry about that
because if you have an HDR buffer
obviously this stuff is itself in frag
color you like you don't have to do this
in your main draw pass because you can
do this later since the information is
still contained you know within frag
color CU you can see the only input here
at all is fra color I mean obviously we
have threshold intensity and Bloom
weights but they're obviously related to
bloom they're they're kind of Bloom
parameters as you can see here that are
actually constants what's threshold
intensity that's a uniform right so the
only input here that is calculated here
is the frag color which is also written
out to the texture attachment so my
point is you don't have to do that here
if you don't want to uh but also it's
fine if you're just doing this kind of
rough Bloom uh it's fine to do it there
so that's why we've got two attachments
here um and then yeah I guess we're
ping-ponging between uh the two so we
have like current frame buffer for
example we're going through this and
we're going to bind one of them as our
render Target then we make the default
Trader active which probably just going
to do use program yep and then we're
setting all of our uniforms uh and then
this is Bloom so yeah generally we just
have the bind vertex array which is our
rectangle we just have a full screen re
rectangle you can also use a triangle if
you want but I guess we're using a
rectangle here judging by the name where
binding the sky box as texture one
texture zero and the current texture as
texture one current texture is one of
the two textures I thought this was used
for I thought this was oh is this yeah
okay right so that's the opposite frame
buffer so that's what's happening so you
can see that these two things are the
this is identical this part as you can
see but here it's 2 and one and here
it's one and two right so what's
happening here is it's the opposite
we're rendering to one frame buffer but
binding the other one as an input so if
two is an output one is an input if two
is an input one is the output I should
have said that the same way one output
equals two input and two output equals
one input um so that's what's happening
so we're taking in each other kind of uh
and that's why we have to do the Ping
ponging because I guess it's it's
Progressive in some in some way usually
you would have just uh an accumulation
buffer and your final image buffer but
uh I guess you could do it this way as
well although maybe that's part of the
reason why we're seeing that weird
brightening towards the end because
something is maybe not quite right if
you do it this way uh but yeah the
actual draw we're seeing over here um
because draw arrays we'll just draw
those six indices as you can see we
don't need an index buffer if you're
doing this uh I mean you have to
redefine the the vertices so if we have
if we take a look at w vao then you can
see that we've got six vertices and some
of them will be redefined so like this
left top is also here left top uh you
can avoid that by using an index buffer
but it's not really a big deal uh if
you're just drawing a rectangle but
neither is drawing a rectangle this way
you could not do this you could use a
computer Shader you could Define the
vertices inside a Vertex Shader and just
issue a draw command with six and that
way you wouldn't even need a Vertex
buffer so there's so many different ways
you could do this uh honestly it's
almost not not worth talking about it
unless you're interested in me talking
about it but uh that's basically where
the main pass happens and then we move
on to postprocessing I think I'm going
to end this video here because it is
getting it's getting long uh I I think I
was correct with my suspicion that this
will become a multi episode series
taking a look at this project so far I
like it I think it's a really good like
subject matter I think it's really good
to talk about there's a lot of stuff we
can unpack here and suggestions we can
give uh you know as to how we would
improve this code it's making me uh kind
of excited to get back into the R racing
series and and um actually add path
racing to Hazel as well because that's
kind of half done but I hope you guys
enjoy this video if you did please don't
forget to hit the like button uh if you
notice anything here that you'd like me
to expand on let me know if you like how
deep I'm going into all of these open
gel and rendering things uh and you want
to hear more of that let me know as well
in the comment section below don't
forget to check out brilliant.org Theo I
hope you guys have an amazing Christmas
and New Year holiday season all of that
and I will see you guys I think probably
next year goodbye